Dong! Dong!
There goes the grandfather clock.
It's 2 a.m. Time to get up.
I wonder what Becky and Dan are doing.
Look at this! They're sound asleep.
Lazy people! It's time to get up.
I want to play.
Come on! Wake up!
Where's my mouse?
I want to play with my mouse.
"Go away, Alistair,"
says Becky.
Oh, you'd rather play What's Under the Blanket?
Okay. Pounce! Pounce! Pounce!
"Stop it, Alistair!"
Says Dan.
Hey! You just pushed me off the bed.
I know you didn't mean to do that.
Let's play something else, something that isn't so rough.
"Okay, Alistair! Out you go."
What? You can't put me out.
I don't want to go out.
I want to be with you!
It's lonely out here.
Come on. Let me in!
If you don't let me in, I'll find another way to entertain myself.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
I know I'm not supposed to be up here.
But you're not entertaining me.
Oops.
Don't worry, I'm okay.
As for that vase, well.
It was kind of ugly, don't you think?
Now I'll find something else to do.
Something that isn't so dangerous.
I know! I'll play Kitty Super Hero!
I'm watching for burglars.
All clear to the east, but there's trouble to the west.
Oh. It's you.
"Honey?"
Says Dan.
"Where are you going?"
"I can't sleep,"
Says Becky.
"I'm going to read."
"Come on, Alistair,"
Says Becky.
"You can come with me."
Well, okay, if you really want me to.
But no love stories. I hate love stories.
"Hey! Look what I found,"
Becky says.
My mouse. How nice.
But I've had a tough night.
I'm ready to sleep.